SPEAKER 1: Well,
welcome, everyone.
Thank you for being here.
Excited to take some time today
to talk about this new book
and to introduce you to the
author and my friend Amy
Carroll.
She's the author of the book
"The China Factor," which
we'll talk about today.
For those of you who
haven't read it yet,
it's been endorsed
by Harvard, Stanford,
and the forward is written by
the chairman of the Silicon
Valley Bank.
She and the book were recently
quoted in a "Forbes" article,
for those of you
in the room which
is at the back, that talked
about Hillary and Donald,
for those of you here in the
US and how this topic that she
talks about is actually the one
common factor between the two
of them.
So if you have a chance to
read that article, please do.
Well, let's get started.
Welcome.
AMY KARAM: Thanks,
Suzanne, yeah.
I'm happy to be here
SPEAKER 1: So for
those of us that
haven't deep dived
the book, tell us
about "The China Factor."
What's it about?
AMY KARAM: All right, but
before we get into the book,
I just wanted to take a survey.
How many of you have
either worked in or with
or for emerging markets?
Anybody familiar
with-- raise your hand.
OK, great, we've
got a small handful.
All right, super.
And I just wanted
to set the stage.
I'd love for this
to be interactive,
so if you have
comments, I would love
to hear from you, questions.
And just let's make
this a learning thing
all across the board.
So about "The China Factor,"
what I wanted to start off with
is what it's not
about, necessarily.
So it's not about how
to do business in China,
although it would
be useful for you
if you were to use
it for that purpose.
But what it is, the
main intention of it,
is to equip
Western-based companies
with strategies and
tactics and knowledge
in better competing with
emerging entrants like those
from China.
So China has risen.
They're doing a great job.
They're a strong
force in our economy.
And they do business
differently.
And the premise is that we
as Western-based companies
need to change our
game a little bit.
We need to know that
emerging competitors have
different approaches,
and we need
to be more creative about that.
The other element is the
innovation advantage.
And how do we protect
or maintain and evolve
our innovation advantage?
And that's a big element
in the book, too.
So we take a look at
some innovation models
and how we can be innovating
maybe a little bit differently
or learning from each other
in terms of innovation.
So the book starts out with
a little synopsis of what
really has happened, right?
How did China become so strong?
What are the strengths
and weaknesses
of each side, the
West and the East?
And then we get
into a comparison
using the five-part framework.
This is how China and/or
emerging competitors,
how they do business.
And then ultimately, how
can Western-based companies
do business differently using
that five-part framework?
And then we close with
some detailed case studies
just to give you an idea of
how all these elements come
together.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you for that.
And so share with the audience
what this is based on.
Where did the
research come from?
What does that look like?
AMY KARAM: Oh, yeah, OK.
So I worked at Cisco for over
10 years, and a good part
of those years, about
four of those years,
I led a competitive
sales support
program that was sponsored
by the CEO at the time.
So the fun part was Cisco
was going to emerging
markets in a big way.
They said emerging
markets was important.
And also emerging competitors
were becoming a stronger force
and challenging us.
And so we created this program.
I was the global
escalation point.
And so the sales people
from around the world
would tell me about
their strategic deals
that they couldn't deal with
on their own regionally that
had to do with competitors
specifically from China.
And then the other
part of the job
was that I was to report from
a competitive intelligence
perspective back to
executive management saying,
hey, this is what's
happening in the field.
This is what we need
to be more successful.
This is how we need
to change or what
resources we need to bring
to bear in order for us
to be more successful in
this new global environment.
And so the results
were eye-opening.
It was just like, wow, this
isn't business as usual.
It's not like some of
our domestic competitors.
It's not a product
superiority play anymore.
Here it's like, my box
is better than your box,
so I'll win the business.
And that's not what was
happening, especially
in emerging markets and
especially with some
emerging competitors.
So that was the
catalyst for me to say,
wow, this is not a trend,
this is not a blip.
This is, I think, here to stay.
And I wanted to
share my learnings
with other
Western-based companies.
SPEAKER 1: I know it's not just
based on your time in Cisco,
though.
AMY KARAM: Yes, thank you.
So you're right.
So that was the catalyst.
And then I left Cisco, and
I did a lot of research,
and it's based on a lot of
other companies as well.
You'll notice at
the end even there's
a case study of Xiaomi, which
is a China-based smartphone
company; Pinnacle Engines,
which was a startup who actually
developed their products
just for emerging markets;
and other companies,
like we talk about Apple,
we talk about HP, we
talk about Intuit.
And it's also other
industries as well.
So I've tried to pepper it
in with other data points
as well for sure.
SPEAKER 1: So you
just talked about
some eye-opening surprises in
some of your work as a thread.
Do you want to give some
examples of those, maybe share
a couple?
AMY KARAM: Sure.
Sure.
So first it is the
severe price discounting.
And that's no shocker, right?
Most of us know that that's
generally a pretty consistent
market-penetration strategy.
But there was really
no bottom to it.
So I encountered a
lot of escalations
where they'd say,
hey, my competitor
has just discounted
me by another 25%.
I need I need approval
for another discount.
And so we realized
that that wasn't
going to be a successful
strategy for either competitor
and even for the customer.
It wasn't a winning game.
So that was one big thread.
The other was financing,
which we didn't really
get into very much as a
Western-based company.
And that's a real helpful
tool for emerging customers.
So this competitor
would help them
with financing and to an
extreme degree, right?
Sometimes they
would help finance
over a very long period of time.
And that was a real great
value to these emerging markets
customers.
And then another huge trend,
a huge element that came up
was politics, the use
of politics to influence
business decisions.
And we're like, whoa.
Where did that come from?
Like what do we do about that?
It would get
escalated, complaints
from emerging
markets, like we've
been working this deal for two
years, we had it in the bag,
and the 11th hour they just said
it was an influence from above.
We have no idea where
it came from, right?
And it was
government-to-government
influencing for
business decisions
at a more granular level.
SPEAKER 1: So politics
is interesting
and something that
Google obviously
has had some experience
with as well.
So do you want to
talk a little bit more
about some of the
practical things
that you have to think about
and actually do for success?
AMY KARAM: Yeah, sure.
So politics is a huge element
of the whole strategy.
And so because it was
so important in the way
we had to re-vector
our strategy--
so another part of my job was to
train the sales teams worldwide
on how to position vis-a-vis
certain types of competitors.
And so in the book I outline
a five-part framework,
as I mentioned, and I
added-- for those of you
who are business geeks, four
Ps of marketing-- Product,
Price, Place, Promotion.
So I created the fifth
P, which is politics.
So I had the five Ps of
global marketing framework.
And politics, so back to your
specific question, it does.
It happens at a
high level, and you
have your executive management
making pretty big decisions
in terms of market access.
So because this has
become such a big world
but small at the same time,
we need market access.
We want to play in other
people's sandboxes, as I say.
But there are certain rules and
there are certain limitations
that we need to encounter.
And you folks know better than I
when Google pulled out of China
in 2010 for censorship
reasons, et cetera,
that was a big decision.
And the implications were huge.
You could have affected
maybe like 1.4,
1.5 billion people in terms
of access to knowledge.
But there were
really good reasons,
and those were the
boundaries within which
a Western-based company
decided that they did not
want to operate.
However, recent headlines is
they're going back in, right?
So market access is
really important,
and reach is really important.
So the political element is
knowing that co-opetition
is the new element.
It's not that new, but
it's an integral part
of a strategy going forward.
It's not us versus them.
I call it "thus" a
little bit, right?
You combine the two words.
It's how do we all play together
within our own boundaries
and desirables to get ultimately
the success that we need.
So that's it at a high level.
And then how do you, how
do we at the working level
deal with politics?
And politics even happens at
the organizational level, right?
And generally, there's a
pretty negative connotation
to politics.
But what I'm trying
to say in the book is
it's really important, we
can't ignore it anymore,
and we need to embrace
it and apply it.
So how do we apply it
from a sales perspective?
What we did was we educated
the sales teams on some
of the tools available from
the US government, for example,
and the local governments
in different countries.
How can they engage with
their own government
to help influence their
own sales locally?
So reaching out to
the consulates--
how do you get involved?
How do you know that some
of these deal opportunities
are happening early
on in the game?
How do you escalate some
maybe unfair trade issues
that you're experiencing so that
there's maybe some intervention
sooner than later?
And it's not at the 11th
hour when we oftentimes
hear about it
And then we also
organizationally changed.
And we're able to
convince the senior vice
president of government
affairs to shift
the focus from just a policy
perspective to helping
with sales objectives.
So using that
influence that they
have in the government
affairs group for more
of the end result in terms of
numbers and not just policy.
And that was really
effective, too.
We went to
Washington, DC, and we
escalated some of our concerns.
So there's a lot we can do.
And I think it's
really the point
of learning from each other.
It's, OK, this is the situation.
How can you mirror and then
tap into your own resources?
SPEAKER 1: You use some
great examples in the book.
I think it would be
interesting for this audience
to hear your perspective on how
Western-based companies could
potentially evolve or
change things to think
about doing differently.
AMY KARAM: Yeah.
So there's a list.
Of course, we all love lists.
And there's a list of 13 things,
recommendations that we can do.
And ironically it
ended up on chapter 13.
So I think that's a really good
luck thing for some cultures,
mine maybe.
So very simply, go global.
A lot of times, Western-based
companies had been hesitant.
And I don't mean Google.
Let's just set it straight.
There's a lot of companies
that have already gone global
and get the global thing.
But I'm just generalizing here.
It's don't be afraid to
go global if we need to.
The second part is, OK,
while you're out there,
let's move out of emerging
markets being a novelty.
And I think a lot of
Western-based companies
dabble in emerging markets.
Oh, yeah, it's really cool.
Let's try it out.
Let's throw a few people in
there and hope it works out.
Oh, not making the
ROI that we need.
Gotta pull out, right?
It needs to be a
longer-term investment.
It needs to be a commitment.
And you need to know that it's
not just a temporary thing.
Other things like
product development--
make sure that your
product development
is catering or customizing
to local customer needs.
We can't just recycle.
It's not, oh, this is a
mature product in this market;
let's just throw
it over the fence
and see if they're going
to like our old product.
SPEAKER 1: You had
a great example
that we talked about
recently on that in something
that you were working with with
Cisco when they were bringing
product to market.
Do you remember what
we talked about?
AMY KARAM: Oh, yes.
Yeah.
And yeah, that's
the other challenge
with really successful,
innovative companies
who have a
premium-based product is
we're really proud of our
innovations and our products.
And I was hosting some ministers
from an African country,
and they nicely, politely
sat through the presentation
at the executive
briefing center.
And we were talking about how
great our super core router was
and all the features
and functionality,
and it's the best out there.
And then at the end, they
asked a question politely,
thank you for the presentation.
And how does your product
deal with power surges?
What?
And so in a lot of
emerging countries,
the power goes on and off
because it's inconsistent.
And when the power comes on,
there is a power surge-- ff!
And sometimes the
power surge is so
strong it comes through
and blows up the equipment.
So we're asking them to
invest millions of dollars
in this super-duper
core router, and we
haven't helped them
protect that investment
by knowing a very small
detail of their needs, right?
So of course the presenter
was caught off guard,
hadn't done their
homework, didn't really
know what the true
customer needs were.
And we didn't get to answer
the question really well.
So thank you for
bringing that up.
And so it's these
little nuances, right?
So you look through the
list, and you're like,
yes, I know that.
But do we really
know these things?
Do we really think
of these things
before we just jump in, right
down to the execution detail?
SPEAKER 1: Loosely
how do we develop
products for countries and/or
people where we are not, right?
How do we do that effectively?
It that remotely close?
Yeah.
AMY KARAM: Really good question.
And whether it's good
or bad, really it's
the business case that
makes it happen or not.
And that was a little
bit of the challenge
that I've encountered in
the past, is you can say,
emerging markets
really needs this,
and then management will
say, show me the numbers,
give me the estimates.
What are the forecasts?
So if you can give them some
sort of revenue projections, A,
but then the quick
answer is going to be,
oh, but that's so small relative
to our larger revenue stream.
So my other angle to that
is the strategic importance
of addressing that market with
that product or that solution,
right?
So it's the opportunity
cost of not being there.
And a lot of companies are
punished if they're not, right?
When you're slow to market,
and I talk a little bit
about this in there, time to
market is really important.
And you can't dilly
dally and think about it
and analyze too long,
because there are so
many other competitors out
there ready and waiting
and addressing that market.
So even if you do
decide eventually,
sure, we're going to play, you
may have missed that window.
And it's the longer-term view.
You asked me last question
about recommendations.
It really comes down to
really committing and having
that longer-term strategic
view that enables that.
SPEAKER 1: And I think
what's interesting
about your point is as a
developer, so someone who's
in product development as
opposed to the sales side,
you actually talk
about something
in your book about relationships
and patience in the long term
and how important that is.
So I wonder how much that plays
into the development lifecycle
and thinking about making sure
that your relationships are
long term and you're in
there for the long haul.
AMY KARAM: Yeah, huge.
Yeah.
And then when you develop
those relationships,
you get that real
on-the-street data that
helps you support that case.
SPEAKER 1: Right at the
very beginning you talked
about the innovation advantage.
So tell us how Western-based
companies can maintain
our innovation advantage.
AMY KARAM: Yeah.
Thanks for coming back to that.
So the key crux of it is
the innovation advantage
is the coveted prize,
the white flag at the top
of the mountain, right?
At the beginning of the
book, we talk about strengths
and weaknesses of each side.
But ultimately, every--
I'm generalizing,
but every company
of East to West
really wants to be innovative,
because that's really
where the next phase
of growth comes from.
And so we see contingents
of emerging folks coming
to Silicon Valley wanting
to learn the secret of how
is Silicon Valley innovative.
How do you do it?
How do you become creative?
But the idea is that we have
to also be creative, too.
We have to be innovative
at being innovative.
So you can't just
rest on your laurels.
This whole concept of
innovation is evolving.
And as more players from
different backgrounds
are becoming innovative, they're
bringing different business
models.
So we talk about five
different business models.
And a couple of them are
business model innovation,
right?
That's coming from the East.
What are they really good at?
They're really good at
commercializing things.
And again, I'm
going to generalize.
We're really good at making
things, really cool things.
But they're really
good at making money
from really cool things
or even making money
from OK-cool things.
We also talk about supply-chain
or process innovation.
I mean, there's the
reputation of manufacturing.
They've got it down to a T.
So one venture capitalist
who I interviewed
in the book said,
you know, all this business
about bringing manufacturing
back to America, we don't
have the efficiencies.
We don't have the
ecosystems yet to do that.
And some of the Eastern
countries do, right?
And we need to either
establish that ecosystem
or just understand
that, that there's
a different source of
innovation happening out there.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY KARAM: I'm just generalizing
to be more encompassing.
Like it's based
out of China, and I
don't want to just
pigeonhole China
as being the
manufacturing giant,
because they're
evolving out of that,
and other countries
are growing into that.
Bangladesh and Vietnam
are becoming so.
But I mean, it's even
humorous to see an emerging
country like Mexico
outsourcing to China,
or they have done in the past,
outsourcing their manufacturing
to China.
It's like their
unemployment is high.
Why can't-- it is
so efficient there.
They are so smart
about it there.
And let's not even think about
the shipping costs alone.
So that's what I'm saying.
All I'm saying is let's
get more creative.
Let's figure out what's
our innovation 2.0 or 5.0
or whatever the rev
is that we're on.
How are we going
to step up our game
and learn from others as well?
SPEAKER 1: So we talked
a little yesterday
about companies that you
thought were doing this well
or an example of a model
that's doing this well
or doing a good job.
AMY KARAM: Oh, yeah, let's talk
about your own Hugo Barra, OK?
So Xiaomi recruited Hugo Barra.
That's one of the 13, right?
Talent is one of
the recommendations.
They recruited your
own Hugo Barra,
who is running the
Android product line here.
They've made VP
Global of Xiaomi.
Their phone is based on
the Android platform,
but they've been criticized for
it looking like an iPhone, OK?
So they're doing
the mix and match.
And then they've applied
it to their Chinese market.
And they've capitalized
on the local--
the Chinese social
media phenomenon.
I think it's WeChat that
everybody's all over, right?
And they have fans, right?
There they're not customers.
They're called fans.
And there's direct
access to the fan base.
And they tell them what's
working with the phone.
So, wow, they just shaved
off millions of R&D
because the actual end
users are telling them what
they need to have improved.
They have real-time, like
almost weekly, software updates,
right?
So they're not waiting
for the next iPhone 6S
to come out in eight months
with line-ups around the corner,
right?
There's that regular updates,
which is also the Android
platform that enables that.
So they've adapted.
They've taken innovation
from all over,
including the talent, put
it in a different market,
used the local market dynamics
to make it super successful.
And what I really like
about this example,
too, is they are very
shrewd about knowing
that this model isn't
going to necessarily work
as they go to other countries as
they do their market expansion
strategy.
So for example,
in the Philippines
they don't do a
lot of chat, right?
They don't do a lot of Twitter.
And they know that.
And so like, OK,
that's not going
to be a success element for us,
nor is the fact that our CEO is
a rock star in China, right?
So that's not going
to be-- how are
we going to modify our market
expansion strategy to be
successful elsewhere?
So, yeah, that's
just one example
of doing a combined strategy.
SPEAKER 1: How worried should
Western companies be about IP?
AMY KARAM: It's a big deal.
Everybody should be
worried about it.
Eastern companies should
be worried about it, too.
And that's the ongoing debate.
In fact, there was
another headline recently
about the word "iPhone" being
used for another product.
I think they were just
leather goods in China.
And it was in the courts.
I hear some head nods, right?
There was a debate
over many years,
and their court said it was OK.
So then you get into
international law
and regulation.
And then sometimes you bring in
the World Trade Organization.
What does the World Trade
Organization say or do?
But then you have to figure
out, does that country
or that competitor care?
What are the implications?
So, yes, we need to care.
And in fact,
Michelle Lee is doing
a really great job of that, and
she's quoted in the book, too.
She's heading up the whole
intellectual property
issue for the US government.
And this comes up with the whole
TPP issue, the Trans Pacific
Partnership agreement.
And a lot of people are
saying, this is great.
And then a lot of
people are saying, hm,
we better be careful,
because what's that going
to mean for our own protection?
And it goes both ways, right?
And that comes back
to politics as well.
There's that back
and forth in terms
of protectionist measures.
I know recently,
of course, and you
know as well, China has
pulled back on market access
to a lot of
Western-based countries,
for different
reasons, of course.
But all I'm trying to
say is it goes both ways.
So the government
is looking at it,
I guess is the short answer.
And be very prudent and careful.
Yeah,
SPEAKER 1: So in what
way can governments
be helpful and play a role?
And in what way can
they not be helpful?
AMY KARAM: OK.
So governments
are there for you,
the trade groups, the
trade commissions.
They have contingents that
take you out and help you
with market access.
And they give you
the lay of the land.
They give you contacts, right?
And they give you the heads
up on what yes, what no to do.
And one of the
challenges with that
as well is that we have
a very fair government,
and they don't play favorites.
So the extreme, the extent to
which they will help companies,
is very limited
because they have
to be very fair to everyone.
They can't favor any
particular company
in a particular industry.
So it gets very tricky.
And they're very aware
of that challenge.
Because other
countries' governments
are much more
aggressive when it does
come to presenting a
certain company abroad.
So I guess they're
looking at it,
but it's very
difficult to change
based on our democratic
fairness system.
And what was the
second part of that?
SPEAKER 1: How can
they not be helpful?
AMY KARAM: Yeah, that's sort
of how they're not helpful.
And they need to just get
more involved, to be honest.
There's a lot of groups.
And so for example in the
high-tech industry, even
competitors have
been coming together
to share some of their
challenges and their complaints
and going as a cooperative
group to the government
to present some of
these challenges
and ask them to make some
changes in how they present
or represent us abroad.
I mean, quite simply, even
with the trade agreements,
how are we really
leveraging those like China
and other countries do?
So there are ways that
we can step it up,
but I think it's a
slow, ongoing process.
SPEAKER 1: Companies
that you think
are just not doing this
well, or did you see examples
of this not working well?
AMY KARAM: Yes, sometimes
we're just too arrogant.
And we don't-- I am
going to generalize,
so I don't want to name names,
but as Western-based companies,
we don't get it sometimes.
And I talk about
cultural IQ in the book.
And again, we've all been very
sensitized to that, especially
here in the US and
in Silicon Valley,
but it's really taking
it to that next step
and really appreciating
the local nuances
before we just dive in, because
they'll quickly throw us out.
And then we look baffled
when it doesn't work.
I'm just I'm just
thinking back to just even
a stint that I did
in South Africa.
And we went in
literally for two days,
did a little bit
of meetings, did
I'm embarrassed to
say a 24-hour safari.
Yes, we did see almost
all the animals that we
needed to see in 24 hours.
And we flew out, and we
felt really good about it.
But we didn't get the business.
It's just, why?
Why didn't they?
Well, because you can't.
You can't just swoop
in, fly in, and expect
to build that relationship
instantly just because we've
got brand equity.
SPEAKER 1: There was a piece
in the question about financing
and government
involvement in financing,
specifically using
China as an example,
and whether that's a
model that will continue
or whether the model will
actually look very different.
AMY KARAM: Yeah,
and then there was
a second part we'll get to, too,
which was really interesting.
So yeah, let's get
to the financing.
I'm glad you brought
that up, because this
is a really huge challenge
for Western-based countries
and companies.
So the good news is-- and
I'm happy to talk about this
because I've been very
passionate about it--
we have a lot of international
development banks
that can tap into this, right?
So I would get the complaints.
It's like, hey, how do
I compete with this?
There's financing.
They just gave this
company $10 billion
over this amount of time.
Like, sorry, we don't have
that kind of cash to give out,
nor would we, because
that's not what we do.
However, let's look
at these programs.
So there are international
development banks
that you can tap into.
You can allocate maybe
half a headcount or one
or two headcounts for it.
And all you do is comb the
projects that are coming up.
There is cash waiting to be had.
And it's really bridging
that private sector
to that customer in the emerging
country and saying, hey,
we can help you with
that development.
And let us help you
fill out the forms.
And whoa-- voila-- you
just helped your customer
finance the purchase
of your equipment.
And by the way, you just
established a relationship
because you're
helping them execute
in ways that they may not have.
So that's just one
small way to do it.
And then it's also-- companies
can get a little bit more
assertive with risk-taking.
So Cisco had Cisco
Capital, and we
were very conservative about who
Cisco capital put money out to.
But eventually, we
came to the realization
that, hey, we're really
serious about emerging markets,
and perhaps we are
ready to have a fund,
a special strategic
fund, for key business
that is really
important for us to win.
And we're going to be very
diligent about assessing
who we lend that money
to, but hey, why not?
And that just shows a little
bit more of a commitment.
Now let's get back
to your question.
You also talked about
pockets in the world
that would influence
product development because
of the financing?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
AMY KARAM: Yes.
The quick answer is yes.
So she's essentially saying,
based on local market needs
and trends, especially
from a technology usage,
is that going to influence
product development locally?
And is it not going
to be centralized?
Is innovation not going to
be centralized in one place?
Absolutely yes.
Yes, I say very emphatically.
That's the point.
We need to start looking at
that and localizing innovation
based on local customer needs.
SPEAKER 1: How are people
using this material like today?
AMY KARAM: Yeah.
So I did take a lot
of pride in the fact
that this is-- I wanted it
to be a practical guide,
like a toolbox for business
people to kind of go through
and see what they can implement.
So it's a checklist.
There's a framework inside.
I even have like
a rough template
in the back where you can
get your folks together
and strategize about your
next global expansion endeavor
and ask yourself
certain questions.
But I'm also giving workshops.
And I like to facilitate
the discussion
and get the ball rolling.
And a lot of times it's at
corporations with similar teams
that are trying to build their
global expansion strategy.
And it's stirring the pot
and getting them to think
about certain elements.
And I love seeing the
thread of influence, right?
So it's looking at the
five-piece framework,
and as simple as
it may sound, when
you look at the
competitive dynamic that
might rebut your
strategy, it really
shows you how you might
want to reconsider
and how a decision in
one element or one area
will influence the other areas.
So it's that puppeteering and
really thinking it through,
through the workshops
and the courses.
It really makes an
impact at the end.
SPEAKER 1: Great.
Just maybe on a closing note,
there's so much in this book,
and it's wonderful to read.
And there are
controversial pieces,
and one can sometimes
leave feeling worried
and/or challenged.
But you are so positive.
So tell us what makes you so
positive just about this topic.
AMY KARAM: I think the
reinforcement from industry,
from people that have lived
it, people who were there.
You mentioned Ken Wilcox,
who wrote the forward.
I mean, just the
validation from people
out there that are like,
yes, this is a need.
This needs to be done.
And the idea that we all
do need to work together,
the idea that it's co-opetition.
It's no longer a
competition game.
We need to learn how to learn
from each other equally,
and that's also playing
in each other's sandboxes
and learning how to do
that respectfully given
our different boundaries
and limitations.
So I just think it's necessary.
We just need to figure
out how to recalibrate,
and everybody will
be successful.
SPEAKER 1: Great.
Thank you.
Well, thank you for that.
Amy is going to stick
around a little bit
to answer questions for those
of you that are in the room
and would like to stay.
Thank you so much
for coming, Amy.
AMY KARAM: Thank
you for having me.
I had a good time.
SPEAKER 1: Great.
AMY KARAM: Thanks, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]